The Easter Island moai are absolutely magnificent.
They're huge carved structures, they're carved out of solid rock.
The largest erected moai are about 10 meters or 33 feet tall.
They've been estimated, the large ones, to weigh up to 75 tons or more.
And how the Easter Islanders did this is absolutely startling and enigmatic.
They even had bigger plans actually.
In the quarry, you can observe an unfinished moai.
And that unfinished moai is under order of 21 meters long, about 69 feet...
...and estimated to weigh over 250 tons.
How they erected these, how they carved them, is still a mystery.
If you ask the native Easter Islanders how it was done,...
...as Europeans have asked for the last 200 plus years,...
...they don't give you a, quote, "rational, Western" explanation.
They say it was done by mana...
...and that statues walked to their locations,...
...or that it was simply mana.
What they mean by that is there's a supernatural or spiritual...
...or we might call psychic force that moved,...
...somehow transported the statues.